More than two months into the war in Ukraine
and both sides are taking heavy losses. While
the bombardment goes on, Moscow has kept up its
relentless propaganda, accusing NATO of conducting
a proxy war with Russia. My guest this week is
Lesia Vasylenko, politician and human rights
lawyer, who joins me from Kyiv. What makes her so
sure Mr. Putin wouldn’t press his nuclear button?
“In all honesty Putin has made so many
claims which he never went ahead with.
Saying that he is willing to
deploy nuclear weapons in Ukraine
would be suicidal to him and to his own
country and his own people as well.”
In recent weeks she has had
blunt words for the West
and NATO – accusing the alliance of ‘cowardice’
and ‘watching the war as if it were a movie’.
Does she still feel that way? And what
about a future peace deal with Russia?
Is there any sign at all of what it might look
like? All that and much more on Conflict Zone
Lesia Vasylenko, welcome to Conflict Zone.
Thank you. It's a pleasure to be here.
More than two months into this war, some 5 million
of your people have left as refugees. But now
hundreds of thousands are coming back, sometimes
against the advice of local authorities. What does
that tell you about your people, your country?
It's a resilient and stubborn people that
Russia has to deal with. And we are very
confident in our victory and very confident
in the victory of freedom and independence.
And the people who you are seeing
coming back are the people who,
more than anything, want to live
in a free and independent Ukraine
and are prepared to do everything to rebuild
it from the wrath of Russia's aggression.
We've seen Ukrainians forced
to confront unbelievable pain
and loss almost on a daily basis. Some
have spoken in interviews about their
continuing disbelief at what's happening
to them. Do you share that feeling?
Every single Ukrainian has lost something in
this war. The worst is people having to endure
losses of close ones like family members and dear
friends. People have lost property, have lost
houses, homes. Everyone's at a loss. Why it
happened? Because of Russia. We know it very
clearly now. How it was possible to even go as
far as the Russians did with all the crimes they
are committing currently in the territory
of Ukraine. This is something unfathomable.
This is something that many Ukrainians,
myself included, still cannot puzzle together.
What have you learned about
yourself during this period?
A lot. I think that myself, like many other
Ukrainian women, we uncover the strength
that we never knew we had before. These past
two months and a bit have been about unity
and have been about resilience for every single
person, for every single family in Ukraine.
We have discovered all, myself included,
that we are a strong people. We are a nation,
a united nation, and a nation that really, really
loves its country and is prepared to die for it.
And the knowledge, as you say, prepared to die
for it. But the knowledge that life could end
today, tonight, tomorrow for you and
those who you care about. Is that
an ever present feeling? And does that sap
your focus or does it in a way inspire you?
I've learned to live with it personally,
and so have millions of Ukrainians who remained
in Ukraine. It's a strange feeling that, you know,
that it can all end tomorrow. But I think the
fear of losing freedom and losing life in a
free Ukraine, losing the home is greater
than the fear of losing your own life.
You mentioned the crimes that are being
committed and you've been keeping track
of some of the war crimes allegations that
have been piling up against Russian forces,
especially when it comes to the treatment of women
and girls. How shocking has that been for you?
That is exactly what my mind cannot put
together. The puzzle pieces are there,
right in front of me, on the table, with the facts
of the rapes committed against Ukrainian women,
Ukrainian children, Ukrainian unarmed men. I
have the facts of numerous tortures. They are
all there. Laid out on the table sometimes with
absolutely devastating pictures to go with them.
But my brain cannot process the cruelty
behind it, the intent and the violence. And
this is the restlessness with
which I also had to learn to live,
with the restlessness of the brain, which
then leads to many sleepless nights.
Do you believe that Russian commanders
have ordered these crimes that are
alleged to have been committed or
simply turned a blind eye to them?
I believe that it's a strategy of the Russian
army as well as of the leadership of Russia as
a country to destroy Ukraine and Ukrainians in
every way possible. What the Russians are doing
is more than just physically killing Ukrainian
soldiers. They are trying to erase the Ukrainian
nation from the face of the earth and they
are doing this in so many different ways.
The fact that our children
today, for more than two months,
have been deprived of proper education, the
schools are closed, the kindergartens are closed,
the universities are closed all across Ukraine,
there's only online schooling. The children
are not in schools learning new things,
not socializing with their kids,
but they are hiding in bomb shelters. They are in
the basements, hiding from Russian artillery and
from Russian soldiers who are hunting them down to
kill them, to torture them, to rape them. And this
is a future generation of Ukrainians which will
be growing up with huge traumas and with very,
very limited education and learning skills. This
is Ukraine we are talking about: a European nation
which has prided itself for years in the number
of literate people, literate children, of the
successes, educational successes,
of the children in schools.
And Russia is taking that away. They
are destroying that deliberately.
What about the chances of bringing
winnable prosecutions against any of
the soldiers that have been committing
these acts? So far I believe ten
have been identified as suspects from the unit
that occupied Bucha, where the bodies of civilians
apparently shot in summary executions were left
lying in the streets. Do you have any hope that
these people might be brought to
trial, might be brought to justice?
I'm confident that justice will be served, will
be served in the Ukrainian courts and within the
Ukrainian justice system. It will be served
in international judicial bodies such as the
International Criminal Court, International Court
of Justice. And I firmly believe that eventually
the world will set up a special criminal
tribunal for Putin, all his cronies,
all the generals and all the soldiers who
have been committing war crimes in Ukraine.
Talk to me, if you will, about life under
occupation in Kherson, for instance.
Is there anything in Russia's behavior
there that allows you to form any view
of their long-term aims, the Russians long-term
aims. I gather the mayor has been replaced. The
currency is being replaced with Russian rubles.
Reports that Russian textbooks have been brought
into schools, that the Internet has been
disconnected and reconnected to Moscow's
own system. Is this the template, as
far as you're concerned, preparations
being made for permanent occupation of
the places where they are at the moment?
It looks like it. I mean, you asked me a couple of
questions back about whether there's a fear about
dying. And I said to you that there's a fear about
losing this freedom. You can rephrase it by saying
that it’s a fear of living under such conditions
that you have just described of occupying Kherson,
where you just don't lose everything, like
physically because your home is destroyed,
but you are told how to live. You are being
deprived of information channels. You are
being deprived of the language, of your history,
of your currency, even. And you are being told
that this is it, this is how you live now:
you have no choice. And I think this is the
worst fear that every Ukrainian has. And for us,
Kherson, Melitopol, Mariupol, they are all cities
which epitomize what the Russians are trying
to impose on all of Ukraine. And again,
this gets the Ukrainian nation even more united
and even more determined to fight even harder.
What's the role of a of a politician like
you under these circumstances? What can
you do for your constituents? How do you
even keep track of the living and the dead?
Today it's much easier than back in the
day, I imagine, because of the social media
and because everybody literally has devices
with Internet and can do a wider outreach.
And this is how we learn today of the needs of the
people. The role of politicians is to be here on
the ground with the people of Ukraine, supporting
them, liaising them with the partners, the
international partners who can provide assistance
and who can provide relief to the various needs…
And we're talking about basic needs here.
We're talking about getting food to people,
medicine, care for the sick and
elderly, that sort of thing.
Humanitarian aid. Absolutely.
If you want one word for it.
How and at what level do
the mechanics of daily life
continue, though, under this constant bombardment?
Actually now it has become more or
less back to normal, if you like.
I'm talking now from downtown Kyiv. I see in
the street to a lot of cars, a lot of people
passing by. The shops are reopened. The
cafes are reopened. Nevertheless, we have
air raid sirens sounding from time to time
and we learn to live with it in the background
and learn to make the best of it. And every
single person has found a space in their life
for volunteer work, for helping others who are
worse off than they are. And the same goes for
parliamentarians, politicians, for government
officials. Apart from our regular duties about
writing laws, debating them in parliament, voting
on them, discussing them in committees, we find
a lot of space and a lot of time for coordinating
volunteer work, for coordinating humanitarian aid,
for coordinating military assistance to the
different territorial defense units and to the
different military units even. So, everybody's
doing their bit to keep Ukraine safe,
to keep the community safe, and at the end of the
day, to keep their families and themselves safe.
You said recently that 80% of your thoughts
are directed at the now, the war, but 20%
is thinking about the future and about
reconstruction. How vital is that from
a practical point of view and I suppose
from the point of view of morale as well?
It's absolutely important to look to the future,
to know your past and to act in the present. So,
of course, the conditions are such today that we
have to concentrate on the present to survive,
and that's the main thing. But then again, we're
talking about people coming back to Ukraine. We're
talking about people coming back to find
destruction in the towns that have been
occupied by Russia and have been freed by
Ukraine. And these towns need rebuilding.
This is just a simple example as that.
And to rebuild them, there needs to be a
vision of rebuild. There needs to be a plan
like there was a Marshall Plan for Europe,
there must be a certain plan for Ukraine
today. We call it the Brussels plan,
because essentially it's the EU institutions
which have come forward and which have started
to devise, devise a certain scheme as to how
to renew Ukraine and how much money needs to
be allocated. The UK, although already not part of
the EU, but the UK is playing a big role as well.
There's a whole team of British economists which
is now working with Ukrainian specialists and
experts to also devise a plan of economic recovery
which would touch also on the energy sector,
on the agricultural sector, on the industrial
and trading sectors. So work is being done.
But of course the Ukrainian counterparts
cannot dedicate 100% of time to that work.
Mrs. Vasylenko, on the political front,
you've recently been very critical of the UN
Secretary-General Antonio Guterres because he went
to Moscow a few days ago before going to Kyiv.
What did he bring back from Russia? Anything that
your government thought was worth listening to?
He brought back a missile attack on a building
in Kyiv which was destroyed and several people
died from that missile attack and ten or so were
injured and taken to hospital with heavy wounds.
Apart from that, not much has resulted.
Not really his fault, though.
Not. Not really his fault. No. But, you know, the
point is that I think, this is the point that I
tried to make many, many times, is that the UN
needs reform. The UN as a system has failed,
has failed big time to prevent wars in the past
and to prevent this war, Russia's aggression,
which has been going on for eight years
now. Russia staying on the Security Council,
having veto power, is absolute nonsense. I mean,
Russia is responsible for the insecurity in the
world and the instability in the world today.
And they are there, making security decisions.
We have, as Ukrainians, time and time again raised
the issue about the reform of the UN system.
We were not heard. Then when we have the Secretary
General first going to Moscow and then coming to
Kyiv, that also doesn't make sense. Why go and pay
the respects and the dues to the aggressor first?
Come, come to Ukraine, see what Russia has done,
and then go to Putin with the demands, not the
other way round. This was the point I was trying
to make. But ok, to be fair, to be fair, after the
secretary general's visit, the evacuation of the
people from Azovstal, the steel works in Mariupol,
has started and has had many successes. So I'm
grateful for that. I would love to believe that
it's because there were these negotiations with
the UN Secretary General, and if that is the case,
then with great gratitude and great respect,
I say thank you to the UN Secretary General.
Along with other Ukrainian MPs you've spent
some time shuttling between Western capitals,
explaining Ukraine's position, its requirements,
its views, and especially its suffering. And
you've heard a lot of overarching expressions
of solidarity and promises of full support,
but you haven't been that impressed
with them, have you? A lot of them.
Not with all of them. Words are words and
words are important. The solidarity messages,
they are well received here in Ukraine. They
also allowed the Ukrainian people to go on for
so long because knowing that there's this --and
feeling this immense support from every single
country in Europe, almost every single country in
Europe on the continent, was a great push for the
Ukrainians to keep going. To know that we're not
alone in this. And to know that the big European
family to which we strive so much, is there with
us. That's important. But of course, what I would
like to see more of is that these words would be
backed up by action, and we are slowly getting
there. So Ukraine is getting weapons and Ukraine
is getting more help in terms of humanitarian,
financial assistance, and Russia is getting more
and more sanctions around it. And these sanctions
are becoming more robust. The only thing is that
it would have been better for everyone’s sake,
not just for Ukraine, if all of this was
happening faster and a couple of months back.
But then time a few weeks ago, you accused
Western countries of doing the bare minimum
and standing on the sidelines watching Ukraine
as if it was a boxing match or a TV documentary.
You've changed your view since then. There's
a lot more than the bare minimum, isn't there?
You know, today when I see the lists of the
weapons which are being delivered by the Western
allies and when I know for a fact from reports
of the military units that I know personally,
that these weapons get to that, to where
they're supposed to get, and they are being
used for good use, then I have
no reason to be unhappy about it.
I mean, these weapons and this support, the main
idea is for it to keep coming until the plague
of Russia's aggression is stopped and return
back into the within the borders of Russia.
You wanted a no fly zone.
You didn't get it. Do you want NATO's
troops fighting alongside you in Ukraine?
Well, that would be always the preferred option.
But you understand why they're not.
At the same time, although that's always the
preferred option, the more we have allied powers
here side to side with us fighting for freedom
and for democracy and for peace in the world
the better. But at the same time, Ukrainian
army has proven itself to be absolutely
self-sustainable when it comes to fighting of the
Russians. As long as we have the means to fight
with and if the NATO powers and the international
community provides us with those instruments,
provides us with those weapons and the armaments,
then we're good to go. We can withstand Russia's
aggression. We can keep fighting for the rest
of Europe. We can be the protectors of Europe
while protecting ourselves and
our freedom at the same time.
But when Putin has openly referred to
his nuclear arsenal and has put it,
he says, on a higher state of alert,
you wouldn't expect the West and NATO
in particular not to take that
threat seriously, would you?
In all honesty, Putin has made so many claims
which he never went ahead with, saying that he
is willing to deploy nuclear weapons in Ukraine
would be suicidal to him and to his own country
and his own people as well. And it's a good
thing that it's not just him alone, Putin alone,
who's in charge of pressing that one red button.
There's a whole line of command to start deploying
nuclear weapons. And in all honesty, if Putin has
gone completely insane, which is clearly the case,
not all of his generals and not all of the
people in the line of command in Moscow
have gone as badly insane as to wish
death upon themselves and their families.
Do you still think that the UN and NATO,
as you said in a tweet on March the 13th,
are showing weakness and cowardice.
As I said, the UN needs reforming and very fast.
NATO is NATO, I mean, in all fairness, NATO is
abiding by the rules in their rulebook. Fair
enough. But at the same time, the different NATO
states are showing more, more confidence and more
courage than that whole organisation put together.
And I think this is the courage that Ukrainians
expect from their partners. Now there's a snap
line going around saying be brave like Ukraine
and this is what we want from our friends.
But cowardice is perhaps an
unfair criticism, isn't it?
An unfair criticism of what?
Of NATO and the U.N.?
Well, look, the UN as an organization has deep
structural problems. I've covered already the
ground about Russia being a country with a veto
power on the Security Council, being responsible
for the insecurity. The UN could have sent
peacekeeping troops into Ukraine through a General
Assembly decision. It hasn't done so for fear of
provoking World War Three. But in all honesty,
Putin would never dare to attack any other country
for the very reason that he has no resources
for doing that and for the very reason that
he's concentrated on Ukraine and maybe a couple
of other Eastern European countries, because
Putin, his goal is to rebuild a Russian empire.
This is the ideology behind this war. This is the
ideology behind how Russia functions as a country.
They want an empire. They feel great in an
empire. They want to bring empires in the worst
possible sense back from the history books. This
is what they are doing. They're not interested in
going ahead with wars in, I don’t know, Asia,
Africa or the Americas because they would not be
able to pull it off. And when the world stands
united in the same way that Ukrainians stood
united against Putin, there would be nothing
that he could do. This war could have stopped.
Way, way earlier, the three days that the
international experts were giving us as a nation
for standing up against the second largest army
in the world could have been really three days to
end this war. If NATO forces, UN forces would have
intervened in time this war could have been over
in three days, but it could have
been over for Russia in three days.
There are plenty of Western experts who dispute
your assurance that Putin would never press
the button and use his nuclear missiles.
But I want, in the time we have left, to
look at where the war might go now. A month ago,
President Zelenskyy said that negotiation was
the only way out of the conflict. But he added,
‘You cannot just demand from Ukraine to recognize
some territories as independent republics.
These compromises are simply wrong. We have to
come up with a model where Ukraine will not lose
its sovereignty and its territorial integrity’. Do
you have any idea what that model might look like.
That model is very simple. I mean, Russia's
committing a crime, a crime of aggression.
There's no doubt about that. I think it's very
much clear for all of the international community
what Russia is doing. That crime of aggression
has clear criteria, it’s described in a number of
conventions. And with that, there's also
consequences which pertain to when a crime
of aggression is committed. And the consequences
are such that, first of all, the crime must be
stopped. Hence, Russia must retreat all of its
troops from Ukraine. The borders of Ukraine
must be reinstated, and then Russia must pay
reparations. It's as simple as that. There's
no other negotiations that can be taking place.
Any negotiations where Ukraine is presumably
requested to give up any territories or to make
any kind of other concessions to Russia will fail.
These negotiations will not bring long-standing
peace to Ukraine, to Europe or to the world. This
kind of secession negotiations will only incite
more aggression in the world. It will inspire
other authoritarian leaders across the
world to follow in Putin's footsteps,
and they will inspire Putin to go in
for more land grabs. The only solution
is to make Russia stop its crime of aggression,
to restore the territorial integrity of Ukraine,
and to make Russia pay for all the crimes
that it has committed in the territory of
Ukraine and for the crime of aggression
against international peace and security.
Lesia Vasylenko, it's been very good to have you
on Conflict Zone. Thank you
very much indeed. Thank you.
Thank you. It was a pleasure.